Mình tà thăm một là chuyện những chúng ông Trung Quốc, CCCTV,
được tin nhà sản lập tập loạn Prince, ông Chang G, đã bị giận nổ từ
công phù chia về Trung Quốc, để điều trang cá cá gục lừa đạo và điều hành sống bạn chơi
phép. Chúng đỏ chành đã bị huy của tịch công phù chia và bị bắt,
tạch nụp anh trong khuyên phổ hợp tóc trong tối phạm xuyên của gia,
giữa Trung Quốc và công phù chia.
Bí bắt cùng Chang có 2 công dân Trung Quốc khác.
Hát thúc đần CCCTV cóng bố hình ảnh Chang bị áp giải mạnh mấy mai trái nở sâu thân
a lời tài trân bị công và chúng đau khi hạt cánh tại Trung Quốc.
Tập đoạn Prince, Donald Chang, lập tình bị Mỹ và anh Trung Phà,
bố hình ảnh cá Trung tâm được đạo trực quyền, quyền một lớn tại công phù chia.
Tập đoạn này sẽ giục đạo đạo bị buôn người để chiếm đó tại sản nạn nhân tòn cầu.
Bắc kìm cho biết sẽ sơm công bố dành xe chuyến át đồng phạm của Chang.
Nông thời tăng cường hợp tóc thực thi phó lột với các nước lạo diễn nhằm trên áp được đạo phuy bên dưới.
Cung ngành tà thăm một, nhưng hàng Trung Quốc có phù chia thông báo,
hình ra lệnh tháng li quyết spine tổ chức tại chính do chảy sản lập.
Nhà trước trách hàng định mặc dù đã điểm chỉ hoạt động nhất trên đuổi và cho bài mới.
Những người đã giủ tiền mặc quyết spine vẫn được giúp theo quy định và người nợ vẫn còn nghĩa bụt chả lại.